fâché mais si mais si mais si c'est dans
le nord de paris qui viennent souvent me
chercher les annonces vont y aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans un château châtoire hui russe alors
c'est parti
cette taurus château aarhus aarhus dans
95 je sais pas c'est un bled 1 c'est un
des pionniers en fait vous êtes les
chroniqueurs de tpm pc ça d'accord ok or
vous c'est gilles verdez c'est ça ça
c'est bon j'avais noté et vous et n'aura
non un cargo cardon ouais nous ne sommes
pas en fait ouais c'est à dire qu'il est
sympa et en plus ils vous paye bastia
aurait fallu série temps de s'excuser
dans ma caisse à g gilles verdez
caroline ithurbide turbide et caroline
ithurbide tu paies téléphone par roland
mec t'as pas le droit
ouais je me fais engueuler je me sois
rigoler non pas du tout ce que je fais
ouais je te rappelle tout à l'heure
ok je te rappelle tout à l'heure ça
merde à tanchet six mois en prison
mobile ou non mais c'est bon ils m'ont
pas vu mon père bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
bien c'est pourquoi je vous arrête
monsieur non du tout non zip au
téléphone par hasard non non non si je
crois que les tuyaux téléphone monsieur
téléphone pardon j'ai dit il mon
téléphone il est là en fait je
griffonnais pas bon vous savez monsieur
que le téléphone en voiture c'est
interdit
l'amande ses 135 euros et ces trois
points d'accord ouais ok tu connais ça
c'est pour vous monsieur
maintenant je veux souhaiter une bonne
soirée monsieur si monsieur roquet qui
consomme chine fait longtemps que tu es
chaud fargo ça fait six mois
n importe qui
c'est remarquer que les gens sont super
énervés lancement en général non mais
moi ça fasse ça me fait sens mans je
sais que je on est tous vachement
dépendant des des influences de des
étoiles de la lune machin tout ça que là
on fait du faux pas de terrain
si je peux en sortant sur la route
je pense entre elles aux instances j'ai
été étonné que tu et ont permis cette
rue qui m'a étonné avec les policiers
tout cas c'est chiant c'est le minimum à
la fin il téléphone de bord et vous vous
êtes vous êtes tout le temps comme ça
incisif avec les gens je suis jean chri
là à là vous êtes gentil quand je
t'explique juste pour le téléphone qui
doit pas faire ça tu est légaliste
mais c'est vrai nom mais vous avez
raison dans trois points lalime dont je
continuerai ouais mais là sinon jamais -
troyes - troyes ça fait trois arrêts
temps reste ici en grattant un peu mais
ce mets toi sur leur espace et un fils
de gosse que l'aller où tu vas tu vas
gênait pour tourner ce conduit
d'accord ça peut pas être pire doucement
et pas très à l'aise quand tu vas vite
j'ai le droit de le doubler par la
droite
tu peux y aller parce qu'il a l'air
encore merci de vos victoires savais pas
que ça existait pas trop de plumes avec
toi tu vois merci enfin je sais pas
c'est un compliment mais moi non plus
mais moins tant que tu es content samba
kanté content tu conduis bien plus on
sert une de paris meilleur ine et puis
on s'éloigne de paris - vous êtes
agressif c'est quoi le sud on peut enfin
chez pas ça va avec
ah non non je suis pas agressif du tout
suscitant il dit j'ai eu des mauvais
chercheurs mais teinté le roi des
mauvais ça va merci et après j'ai pas vu
plus mauvais que toi sinon vous sert à
ça un compliment dont wayne sans doute
mais prend le comme tel mais c'est
dingue quoi tu fais est en fait tu sais
pas conduire du tout tu vois et pas
désagréable mais tu es vraiment mauvais
à part lui là les autres non ça va c'est
quoi ça c'est au [ __ ] cette deuxième
contrôle de fil de la soirée celui
blague c'est une blague
symbian
bonjour monsieur monsieur la police
nationale on a un signalement d'un homme
grand costaud avec 90 qui serai dans les
parages
vous êtes universel oui on est assez fan
boy se regarder un petit peu l'émission
on vous connaît je pense à une petite
imitation away avec plaisir est né où
va-t-on à l'heure qu'il est c'est enfin
je sais pas c'est quoi ça va toujours
aimé moi j'ai pas testé ce match ils
sont là ils sont là fuient remonter
leurs montures ils sont la lgv
extraterrestes ils sont là il faut pas
rester là il faut pas rester là je vous
dis restez pas là on vous dépose un peu
plus loin un monsieur vraiment tant
qu'ils ont pour habitude qui fixe comme
nous mais je suis pas fou et mois ferme
et si les joueurs aient lieu c'est mon
frigo
monsieur décliner votre identité
a procédé tout à fait qu'un mois contre
moi d'après les trucs ou pas est-ce que
tu as pris les trucs que julien bru
bambins y aller en prison comme vous je
crois moi j'ai demandé les gens
devraient forcément mais vous monsieur
c'est voter une à enlever raconté
doucement où commence à me faire chier
pas vous arrêter vous arrêtez pas
d'insulter sa com vous allez me dire
mais brad à gauche conduit à merde tu
apprennes j'apprenne de voitures rayées
les attendez attendez vous savez je le
savais regard n'ai pas peur ils sont
lents regarde vous avez montré que vous
n'allez des mails est loyal et si
longtemps fâché mais celui-ci l'avait
mais si c'est le nord de paris qui
viennent souvent bien
les oiseaux y aller là on va se calmer
vous me laisser gérer oui j'arrive en
forme et en mer non je veux leur parler
on veut leur part et dans ce cas là tu
me connais bonjour tu reconnais moi je
suis il bonjour je suis il est toi tu es
qui débloque ma vie toi tu avais foulée
mais c'est un gros mytho depuis les
bulles lardons il est vraiment audio ue
avait pas un mot plus haut que l'autre